we thought that it was a miss my home
that we say that the Spanish but often
without sanctioned tomorrow ok ok I arrive his
brasileiro and I appreciated two
English ones
ok yes no no no no they settle like
saccon line that is new because already tenia
sentence sentence  of the gray-
speaking car fleet yes no who knows if you are not a notary
maize yes no I can order with masters
carson xperia sound speakers the
library the ex ok evo compartments diana if
then the sympathy or company in bojan
homeland
very well on a little troglodyte  you wait
nas
when it enters but we enter we choose
shaolin always as samos with the sound is
a page which is called sa well ok since
seamus 4 in italy
normally creamy take they entered
as it seems to take you and when you go to
see album impossibility eg
osea what it was  lekesiz in the cups
recommend to as liz noise she as dar
es
or who asks you attend the banner
that re siviero rosales from over caravex
that we study fades lissa that the
possibility of saying  how to give desire s and
salt are his a lot and we have a
noisy ice alessandro to those who green them
difficulty reed and intermediary I can
have how you would be davis alessandro ita
mbengue I may have lasted like the odes or
beta well
we had hopes to those who consider how they
went instead to fall o  number of the
palace does not consider ok because it is
an indication in di cassano from every
thousand difficulties they speak of it because it falls
at the same time on its own data of the bass
right there of the palavela schools is given
if not with the challenges that cada vez o
sistema va désir  qantas palabras not with
him I immediately parried himself and himself a
manera the shoes are as a diversified king
of laughter because as long as we oar we
study the interesting thing but it has its own
cohesive time back demais deficient
and it is important to know that to whom every
difficulty rec that  va per essere is to
rodrigo alive albeit evening to s run from jean
jacques fesch to the microphone since
caravex who has a fluid a microphone
ap antonio savarese e e ora veng  o does it make
sense that when it is a logo de charny
microphone or and I look with eduardo but
that the matador passed then we were
si eduardo waves moses
is a very poor dream
a little difficult a trip is male
so I look a little less not a little corn
corn
ok votes otra vez that when we are a bit
a little deficit and when he is not vamos and
best fashion or microphone cada vez s
disturbance and ceo for example now I am
showing something
nami advantage so much pantoja action
when he has entered fields and don emilio
po  physics dry food then in corso
mazzini
maybe one thing modern images for
microphone and body fashion week does it and it is
called microphone what they are called
amounts no microphones microphones and
when on off alamos must be shown to the
microphone
ok by eduardo on the more moses had
film brazil press all use link already
taken 4 and 6 pavement english might
magic canada
shaggy english advanced macedo enough
time attempted we will take mister cito
with the shield
I prayed  o it is competition and intends to see them
the shadow microphone during which I
look it was ok if eduardo maybe the themes
for gunther sober lemon sobrero system
link you can give input scoop segat
shaved and I find accompanying the
youtube transmission atheist cosche league
august peasant friends are then
prices  pan mia ex coda g as a democristo
match ea pronounces example how
careful it takes rock abuses at home pro
nuncio to live pares that nun tene a
progress is an entity however already exists
when time is studying alema a
village like six album aziz 4 face
like 6  it is known how an ace boys equal to
choose phase a race chino grusin
made by gimenez but is voted for her
tour punta mesco dalida pronounces on
eto'o from pronunciations that of physicist or
only albums album songs
especially house stones mais common
law turned to  cabo non i get
g costumes and gifts if ovi lane vice
al khalis paparo cash allegedly
advise how to separate them coexist is
a mismatch
steve what gives us sense microphone ok
then we listen I say that I am exists
in the language spent by now they are fixed para
pronunciation and that I believe that Russian for
example is very determined today at a good altitude it
is ok I always do is and a new
attempt to pronounce o  principle evo
spend a year saint paul hart always
nuptial because between me there is never space
when already observed an
idiom
but in addition to genetics that makes larcher and
then you do not know in principle it depends on the
manor to study and who knows cisas that
fernando is that the tweets  a lot of experience
and teaching english is better
portuguese sharer who is taking
at university or at least giose idiom
but para mi e su but i am in science
po the example and daisy a fernando os
portghesi feeds better english
spanish and i on credit that and since  ex
portugesi stand and my sons in
portuguese language ten mais deep tongo
steinway sons
very important for itself to be able to over
a songs and now is a new
test pronunciation test and then I see it a lot in
exile but for now in addition to the source
that scutari repeat limit right
principle and not dry and in the best way
to master or not  in line with the
study and that rostan ben scooter in the
opinion of fernanda and cher and rodrigo is
ta men you thorny but please
indeed the huskies are based on the principle
is a bit with you but you take it it faces a
bit more expensive my case  english
flake takes a fa the english princi
meteo car pro is not rubber but whoever
votes languages multiple intervention is not exact
y like losail with hazy best
s found lead me to 6 pronu
ciations you are not municipalities that how it is takin
as if a door buys me a  yes
to sao a poco zanza uprising so if
an important summit well dyslexia
you are curious about us months but it is a situation
that is in English
we are never three occasions and
opportunities he shoots at English
scutari while  and spies enter masters dressed in
English costume but the television in
film is a music enter a no and
the r's we already
know with the exams are not consonant but to put it is valid
but Russian us a case it is possible that the
smart fans are pronounced English
exactly why i fear ovid 80 very
english over opinion crn il iv f
boh i don't know if it helps me with ha ready a
sau mas it's a costume fa la air it's a
match but you don't know when i'm washing the
eviction i'm walking for the parker but
what  cohesive always i'm talking
intentando for us
but i'm flying
ferrand just to start singing will take
dutch has meant for smoking advice
and i on credit and watch that yes you're
in difficulty pronouncing maybe you have to
continue studying but we will have
crescenta or hubble vocabulary  sardines
david dawe idiom reading spitting and
as many professor de polis
1 why yes agorà has difficulty pro
no one knows it is a factor of discouragement
and discouragement within and is negativ  o and
improves and I am a when they study not
me for myths and design and meet design
imago 9 discouraged by a new
pronunciation evo to take the ball france with
the iervolino and like daisy in fernanda it is
important to have neither astoi and it is tasted
fa lar as  para phase it is very
important to me in phase to what he wrote that
I like becks that what is needle
roads phase if these things to do a su
mismo ben fava sivo 6 costa dell air
ruby as I happen at the beginning true pivot
feels in trouble and  a little
frustrated the real difficulties of the
pronunciation mask were that to take alema
and or not chievo if it continues to take
me and fest
maybe if above from polis because we are not
an open time learning the
federal language was preparing an
open time bomb and it is  then so sure nova
pronounced you're so puts in the middle e
mail mail advice no not if its
profits or not
ok the others pre montas above or opens in
discomfort
wellink yes no you can continue these
cassano from the library ch  and it happened that
of the songs that karim participate in
covers to me it is an understanding how it works
and I was always google plus because I am
invited to tholos and to whom I fear cinco
personas church team in short if that
soros that yesterday to participate was not
destroyed and or invite him to the  wedding world
because time and I'm at chess and wants to
participate
no I don't know if ok tightens to those who like desia
and
at page top to take them must not
die as well knows who has to mousse
wishes does not become difficulty the that
goes to me if every network  to sniff at the
library and services and decide to whom yes
which banners he is learning by
studying or new sails learned since they
are your dreams and it was not that not it is
a question of level and a question
that uncovers the suns he was laying out
studying bob  I go to go to the
library in tambay and in the page to
take everything maybe it explodes versus
different different distinct lomas english
chinese bahrami portuguese that i am
studying and fetus tempted  of 120 to the three
links of 67 of as to prepare for
it discussion it conversa eta beta
in fa works with fernando equa diego
words a little to prepare why
to do it portuguese ok the thing to the
library and temus tito album that comes out
above the library that was difficult
procure them does not say buscar and the amount
that they procure but and hopes
how to be functional and always at miss
map ssa misma mustaine library where
on view library minias ominia lin
songs to import thematic parties
change to Portuguese tradition because
that is one is also changing iso  it is
simply to write imports
because if not you then if it is true
as concert novas a library with excuses
sketch that already pays to as that is
drafting is giving a shock he wore himself
and then the ease of power of attorney to
his power of having it is a column  prosthesis
test a pantoja for kenya why not or
protract agents who preferred by sms
this morning the evos and the city and at the
library but it seems deci  I know I always have
this explains cassano de sass in the
same way
tambay maybe I can of sony or cursores
which is a course consists of a 69 of the
songs and when I create the content as
for example a frenando h
who has always created lissoni portuguese
and in the fese competition with  20 liszt sony e
mai sparsi para use usar being
lissone you are eating organized and
not running but I fear stan ben son of sound
playlist or that you create desire and or for
example I can esquire the songs ali to those who
have included sony's suns in a
playlist or  or example if I am
procuring a library weight what is
interesting that I am not a user I have time
para csto of aragon I can put it is neither
a future pro player a playlist above
lissoni supra economy or playlist or that
if ita main fernandez who is helping
him  giving to us we asked in
portuguese can it always be or
fernanda playlist for
beginners for example within is a
real manera books the cliffs lissoni
consumis  mo or then posed shoot ayudar
other links and from me to type is no I can then
procure with the search box the sites
economy to us no and millions economy
has no rice and tin ok but normally if it
works well procure using it
the time to import them are  and that's it and to
alessi voice
to study a lesson that is
provided by and from the English dot
com
perhaps only techniques cli car
over a name name of the crazy phone exam
one thing to whom temus gestures buscarsi or
nombre de palerme novas dura are
of the  'audio or for example follows it was sense
notches british american that there are
stories works in the race when flying
proxy in a portuguese library
i can make a mistake ii soul ii soul goalkeeper
of portugal port of these just
ok of the nas you are above library and
egpc and or worse
lapresse  in spanish velasco music
according to tosi in door the esp and as he has
doubts above these are esaposto
conciliate with todo mundo i quasi post
buy cilia with friend game high
stakes
ok usa we hear both the possibility
of the compartments to the songs the most a
possibility of importing songs and
members who pay buses that do not
pay a limit of the synchro article
articles just mattered but osman
bruce who pays a little important
as he asks  that podemos summed
compartments compartments of a
cohesive library scène o ten
limits of the point of view of author reiter
ok désir one wanted for example a
periodical in principle does not keep direct
to white compartments todo that was
framed while averages and must to
mount o  owner and very tense and
praise mysims case does not answer because both
the problem is a problem it will not break through
in short both it and never for example
hotel told to wikipedia
i res designate itam bay fernanda pre
counted a podcast in portugal and is
both si è the moscow l  'example coffee from
scratch after fernando extended but both up to
paolo no fernando a pound no no
remember that the sylvian pearls a
shot and steph crossover  en t rex kharja
behind a way the moscow i suns
fantastic and at home language and
a pre count maybe we can use
and if then the gas est et a matera in
our library and
a radio podcast that of senses thank and
design and  ideas that he says he does not answer
but in principle he has to vote yes if not
the other age all compartments a
library at interpol I want to use
use it or consumerism important to use but
i tam bel po the compact compartments iran
or ing when he wanted to give him a  rosa or
ds a lot of the segments guard
explicitly as an indication from home wild
card article article is our
system you do not know if I am a real
article I can immediately import
it if quality the possibility of the
mythos member slow link or mismo article
but not  it is compartments a library
ok ok ok
now desist although importing time
boys manor is important but and eco
pearl and kolar and beyond is to use or
on doc malware that is corn rapid  o and
time advantages that already all inclusive
plus including the included fluid entered
when he wanted to import using a bit of the
bookmarklet perhaps not ten that you copy
articular or area but you wanted with the
copy articulate it article para para
polo is in progress in town 6 try well that
copi articular and wired now closed between
schools and compact compartments are a lisa
maximum 6 uses or a bit of bot mike and never
space is not that his post market is
not believe not so it is a fuchsia that was
must on air on tuba and yes  item click
on a cross and or bait if you rent
hobo clegg has paid to turn
import or because I was already amy media and
I go out lido and bookmark and 9 but clarified
that I want to cleanse well canada place
golden state
adebayor ok now I'm not connected
own system
no a few drinks at was leaking today and
marco glimpsed later they stand out but a
bar not a browser and you are neither much
like napoli bonzi rome that the
physical people get them ok but it is very very
good use if  mpre when i'm having a
periodical nice album
interestingly starts very fast course
important nas import for this goes
to the states little is known about serious with
example always ok screen share i'm going to a
eurostar cultural pole to study or to
new york times to be as a screen
saver  women
new york times ok to whom I fear on the new
york times or open an article and or yes and
to whom european jean bookmarklet to whom ok
evo click and you that select
video but to those who are English very well
because it is a device in when enci arco
in russian  in Japanese Sino the que ser
pole to those who English very well you
important and in the article
the axis will open already in the league and to those who need
the possibility to choose
where and ceo euro sectors
alessio is produced smembri delic pol en
studart it is  asked I include yes yes
evidently only yes that
argo console reappears santanche they
copy the tam band copy it or link out of
hatred but to whom not it is that I hate does not
preclude that as well as  I'm in me and as a former
rocker they rely on browsers and why how many
kathleen weiss and import marco min
dismissed versiona ancient text by karen
bookmark no not s was you know first what is to
be ashamed barb respect
arrested wide to whom
you know who I fear ok bookmarklet engine  onu
browser as of race less browser
case use or select mater is no
exception some browser
ok you are not first thing and it is the one for
me is as that you can use
instead you put a browser with a little map but
you are a share happens to  who, since he is
presenting the schlecks time does not
complete mutar a to dad but he is already there but he
is a not covered because it is a fetus that is
that it allows to stop widening and
agora always use a bookmark theo akin
and I just enough just
no no after helped page  that changes or
takes now no they are not deaf
vintage contextual vote signature line it
shows costs kukan a bar still the one
on the cocconato one vote inflates
an article that repeats that
the insurrection  language fusion in
function is projected memo stu darcos
wrote on mind texture 76 so if in
hate the others over experimented on
page on page who on page the list or
when as semi nov aversano ringworm
members who does not taste I go 9 systems
because he was costumed direction  peugeot
system no but maybe no fear it will try with a
I ten accustom it to pasin with wawrinka
as it is that we keep we keep or system
with a few because those who work do
not know that I am blocked stop but it works
because who is traditional form me
I leave the country to those on a diet and with
sports or mascara text it disturbs me
because when that lawler or texture and
tambay and euro corn barking above
example and tolo rice that controls who but
according to learned software understood that
me and me computer all  effect something
that standing pd because normally to those who
warn minimized it minimizes thai
boxing but who has not asked nice
so first page list 1
sober friend three functions system or
what surprise  de lingua something no for a
truth of an alleged general corn that
you know 8 content partner of engagement
and who view English Spanish Portuguese
that restores a continuous count
sergio pezzota set by hideo both
for instyle together or was valid jesus
I don't understand you was said that  demos
si various languages city or mans and the risks the theme
companion de sass confess losin
bet as otis think in sponge and come on an
go continue they could sell and s
ow us there were system a parah
parah practical experience comparison with being syste
google plus hangouts time sadun massa
to sniff for example is to make
people coexist cada vez bribes that
non-residents
from the calculations from the beginning that we will
continue we will continue using google plus will be the
new face and it will be printed to communicate with
the members to explain it system relative
nder ready sour it only counts that I'm
nice  che che osnabruck en v phase room
converse harman hainaut
next week in chinese language man  they give the
tambays they depend on the time what time
that next week
starts from in maniago and four different ones in the
dialect note in a time however that remus
phase that facilitates to communicate sound I
don't know enter and bruno e o member life
while member subissimo and we are
experimenting with  different system shoots
towards which to the system mass false masses by
now his shot is inaccurate that I was
still continue to form that technique
as elisa ass.te mosque and that
shows it although tambay that hughes
experimenta members in three tourism ter hanoun
shoveling interact talent on mismos since
you now it is only technology but ninos of the
municipalities cassano that poses I do not know puts
create a community and interactive
corn corn phase if you love lotito right
overnight the didactic point of view
hold and its through is
what muse writes to discover and that no
then we time  in short, certain fixed idea
is that he is a poet you know what is
best for opening in grey's you know if it
is films to or if to receive or where to po  dcast
thesis and always me you think that I tend to e
commerce
one thing is that, however, to take an idiom it
is precise golf course are no it is decided
that it costs me but it is pro sisal specifies
that it consists of us activities the cards are
doing with it yes it was that  it cost
film stand that attended the fim
because it is very important to contact me
with or corn idiom time going to spend
with rabbit idioms but best vice to
take but presses because of films
heaven difficult very difficult film
I would like 9 years without then during
filing  register difficulties notes
will let you talk about the shop you find and
Japanese but we keep it
as team difficulties comprender o sir mons
film son mais difficult and I preferred
preferred to scrutinize them because times admits
palabras notes image and myths and I
on credit that esmer ur para para
rightly  I project on credit that
left
the apprentice of languages and or vocab
lary as always diego and I
on credit that layer and listen and corn
efficient you take essays by de
paula who hospira mons but of films is
a black mother from the gulf
browser manera corn and simon sting corn
actividad fluid corn and opera is
fine with me I care about you me who is mikasa teo
films del ceco delusional and thangram  sentence to
noemi rai portuguese non rfid systems
green living to have his signature, however, to
learn from branches and scooters green areas
the hawks and film josè como is like a
reward for the stress tests that I
did time flat which seemed to take it
idiom less is an instrument  of the
forecast
now, however, the males and beyond that we are
documentary opinion
ok I very much obliged assisted rais
cover and states if disco discussed and
grounded a neighbor now that he is close
to next I find